[Musique]
bonjour à tous une vidéo où on va parler
d'apple cette semaine a été annoncée
lors de la conférence des développeurs
les nouveaux produits les nouveaux
services lancés qui vont être lancés en
tout cas très très prochainement par un
puck et dans ces fameux service il y a
le home pohdh alors leurs bottes c'est
vraiment l'évolution de ce que doit être
le centre névralgique de la maison
connectée et même un outil
je dirais qu'il va prendre la place des
applications dans les temps à venir
alors le opposent çà ressemble à une
petite boîte une peut-être pas de
petites colonnes qu'on va pouvoir
prendre et posé chez soi qui va faire 10
7,2 cm de haut pour un diamètre de 14,2
cm c'est pas extrêmement grand par
contre c'est relativement puissant vous
avez tout autour de l'appareil cette
twitter et twitter c'est ce qui sert à
développer le sons aigus dont vous
n'avez sept qui sont répartis tout
autour on vous faire sur le dessus pour
envoyer un petit peu de graver et
envoyer de la basse et tout autour aussi
si mitron alors les micros vont servir à
plusieurs choses
la toute première chose ils vont servir
effectivement à analyser votre pièce et
à reconnaître l'emplacement de votre
pote dans votre pièce pour pouvoir
vraiment optimiser la qualité sonore
imaginez lorsque le son se diffuse donc
par deux du point par de l'homme poche
il part silva trouve un mur leçon va
taper et le son va être réfléchi jusqu'à
arriver à vos haut-parleurs qui lui
valent analysés par rapport aux sons qui
a été envoyé il a calculé le temps
d'aller le temps de retour elle
permettra avec un processeur c'est un à
huit ans
de apple ça lui permettra de calculer
est vraiment d'optimisation donc quand
il saura que on peut envoyer un peu plus
d'un côté et un peu moins fort de
l'autre il va être diminuée les missions
sont du côté des tweeters d'un côté et
conserver le volume maximal de l'autre
côté donc c'est vraiment un système qui
est super bien c'est vraiment pour dire
haut-parleurs intelligent et on reste
vraiment dans les objets connectés
intelligents alors autres buts
autre intérêt de ces micro ça va être
effectivement de pouvoir communiquer
avec en pole c'est pas juste un lecteur
de musique connectés que vous allez
pouvoir poser chez vous c'est vraiment
un assistant de vie personnelle à savoir
que vous allez parler à siri tout
simplement vous allez dire 10 séries et
sert effectivement pas reconnaître votre
voix comme vous le feriez avec votre
smartphone avec votre ipad ou avec votre
votre ouvrage avec tous les les objets
connectés de l'écosystème apple vous
dirai à siri ce que vous voulez en terme
de musique est ce que tu peux mieux
cette musique est ce que tu peux jouer
celle là est ce que tu peux ouvrir les
volets si vous avez par exemple des
volets connectés qui sont compatibles
avec apple avec le home kit ça pourra
offrir vos volets allumer votre lumière
avec effectivement beaucaire partenariat
également avec philips you il ya
beaucoup de partenariats donc toute une
maison connectée
le hotspot c'est vraiment le centre
névralgique ses micros sont là pour vous
comprendre pour vous reconnaître qu'elle
même quand il ya de la musique
ils vont re capable de reconnaître votre
son le son de votre voix en tout cas
pour pouvoir comprendre les commandes
que vous voulez et au delà de la
commande de la maison et au delà de la
commande je dirai simplement du fait
d'écouter de la musique
vous allez pouvoir dire je veux regarder
la télé si vous avez l'apple tv vous
allez pouvoir commandes est plein de
choses elles peuvent poser des questions
d'ordre général est vraiment connecter
et communiquer de plus en plus avec siri
d'autant plus qu'on sait que syrie va
vraiment plus loin dans le machine
learning
on a vraiment sur un produit sur un
service série qui vient de plus en plus
intelligents qui va comprendre vos
besoins qui va pouvoir affiner les
propositions qu'elle a pas offert par
rapport à vos goûts personnels
donc on est vraiment quelque chose qui
va être de plus en plus personnalisée et
de plus en plus intéressant après
l'inconvénient d'un produit comme
celui-là c'est qu'effectivement je
dirais que apple rentre encore plus dans
votre maison une fois que vous avez ce
produit là vous aurez forcément que des
produits connectés apple pour votre
intérieur
parce que ça serait dommage d'avoir une
poignée de ne pas avoir tiré une maison
connectée qui correspond qui peut
communiquer en tout cas avec avec cet
outil là alors c'est un produit qui
fonctionne avec airplay deux harpes les
deux qui effectivement qui a été annoncé
sur ios 11 airplane 2 qui vous permettra
de piloter plusieurs hommes potes
l'idée si vous voulez c'est d'en avoir
plusieurs un dans votre pièce principale
pourquoi pas un dans votre bureau 1 dans
votre chambre
un dans votre salle de bain ce qui
permettra en permanence à syrie d'être
connecté avec vous et en permanence
d'avoir la musique dans différentes
pièces
on va pas toujours diffusée au même
volume sonore quelle que soit la pièce
quel que soit le volume de la pièce on
va imaginer une pièce duvet qui sera
plus grande par rapport effectivement à
une salle de bain en règle générale en
tout cas donc on imagine très bien que
le volume sonore sera beaucoup plus
restreint dans les petites pièces et
avec effectivement votre votre iphone ou
votre ipad vous pourrez régler vraiment
indépendamment le volume sonore dans
chaque pièce et ça c'est plutôt pas mal
foutu
autre point intéressant sur le dessus
vous avez effectivement un bouton qui
vous permettra de mettre en lecture la
musique de la mettre en pause mais
également de régler le volume sonore
alors comment ça marche tout de suite on
ne sait pas on a vu qu'il des mots un
petit peu un petit peu sommer le produit
n'est toujours pas disponible
elle sera disponible qu un peu plus tard
mais ça on n'en parlera plus loin dans
la vidéo donc voilà un espèce de boutons
multifonctions sur le dessus après il y
aura effectivement plein d'autres
fonctionnalités comme je le disais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire vous pourrez
demander à siri
quel temps fait-il la météo l'actualité
des résultats du sport mon équipe
favorite appel par exemple appelant
proche a fallu qu'elle perçoit mais
l'élu simplement appelle maman il sait
qu'il maman parce que vous l'avez
rencontré donc dans vos contacts de
cette manière là en ajoutant la petite
annotation basse et ma mère tout
simplement
donc vous avez plein de possibilités qui
s'offrent à vous et il y en aura de plus
en plus parce que à l'avenir série va se
compléter et ça va devenir vraiment un
super assistant de vie que vous allez
retrouver de la même manière sur tous
vos device puisque syrie est connecté à
votre compte
apple est pas simplement un appareil pas
simplement série dans l'homme paul
serait différent éventuellement de syrie
dans l'iphone ou syrie dans l'ehpad pas
du tout c'est une même série avec les
mêmes connaissances les connaissances
très spécifique de vos besoins et de
goût qui seront faites de manière
générale et
et à votre adresse mail est à votre
compte apple apple a vraiment joué le
jeu en annonçant une protection des
données bien évidemment on sait déjà que
ça fait longtemps maintenant que pelé
rentrer dans les foyers un téléphone que
vous posez c'est un micro et une caméra
même si vous n'utilisez pas il ya
toujours du son qui peut être
enregistrer les données qui peuvent
peuvent être diffusés donc il ya un vrai
vrai besoin de sécurité puis c'est un
enjeu majeur c'est la sécurisation des
données personnelles
ils ont vraiment annoncé une solution
qui permet d'en cryptée complètement les
données qui vont passer avec des
identifiants anonyme est vraiment une
protection des données personnelles qui
devrait être optimisé quels sont les
points positifs quels sont les points
négatifs de ce produit à venir alors
aujourd'hui compliquée ce2 de dire
vraiment si ce produit est bien ou pas
dans la mesure oui comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il y pas disponible et
dès lors qu'on l'a pas entre les mains
qu'on peut pas laisser dans les
conditions du réel c'est délicat de se
prononcer par contre on va parler du
concept le concept jeu déjà donné à mon
sens trois points positifs le tout
premier c'est d'abord la musique dans
l'ensemble de la maison paramétrer les
haut parleurs individuellement ça c'est
vraiment une grande avancée je trouve ça
vraiment bien
bon ça existe déjà dans le commerce
c'est pas le truc révolutionnaire mais
ça va dans le bon sens et apple a
vraiment fait un produit qui est sympa
sur ce concept l'heure en tout cas le
point numéro deux que je trouve vraiment
bien c'est la gestion de la maison
connectée
alors la maison connectée apple 1 par la
maison connectée de tout le monde et
quelques jours on parlait de la solution
bosch smartphone d'ailleurs si tu veux
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil à le
lien ici qui est une solution de maison
connectée ça par exemple
au jour d'aujourd'hui en tout cas on
pourra pas piloter cette solution la
solution bosch à partir d' apple parce
qu'il est tout simplement pas de pont
entre les deux entreprises est pour
l'instant en tout cas elle ne
collaborent pas ensemble je ne sais pas
si ça aura lieu à l'avenir toujours est
il qu'aujourd'hui
la maison connectée apple comme je le
disais ne pourra se faire qu'avec des
partenaires apple et des gens qui ont
accepté de rendre compatibles leurs
produits avec la solution apple
et puis le troisième point qui me paraît
être vraiment intéressant et non
négligeable c'est le fait d'avoir un son
optimisé optimisé pour votre intérieur
chaque intérieur est unique chaque
maison à des angles différents que soin
des ongles vraiment droit 90 espèces
dont bhl biscornu aider des pièces un
peu bizarre le fait que vous ayez six
haut parleurs autour de votre pote ça
permettra de complètement personnalisé
le son de votre pièce et de l'optimiser
et de ne pas vous retrouver avec un son
qui trop pourri parce que vous auriez
une réverbération d'un côté parce que
vous auriez leçon qu'ils reviendraient
parce que si ça pas besoin de le poser
au centre de la pièce pour avoir un son
parfaitement claire et parfaitement
diffusé partout
vous le mettez sur une table qui est un
mur qui est une télé qui a une une
huître à côté peu importe le son sera
complètement optimisé et ça c'est plutôt
bien
alors maintenant il ya des points
négatifs 1 on va pas se mentir sur le
concept a toujours pas sur le produit
point négatif le tout premier point
négatif c'est le fait que ça fonctionne
avec apple musique et à ma connaissance
seulement avec apple musique donc si
vous n'avez pas de compte apple musique
ou alou la musique durant a pas de
musique spotify on oublie 10h n'en
parlons pas si vous voulez spotify il
faut et sur la solution amazon ico ou
bien alors sur google sommes là vous
pourrez effectivement utiliser votre
compte spotify
à moins que apple permettent
effectivement une ouverture avec spotify
mais ça m'étonnerait
à mon avis ya pas eu vraiment vouloir
plutôt cloisonné pour qu' il ya des
abonnements qui se prennent de plus en
plus autour de leur solution apple
musique avant tout ce qu'ils
privilégient c'est de développer leurs
solutions leurs propres solutions
ça a toujours été comme ça dans cette
boîte autre point négatif et pas des
moindres au mode n'est pour l'instant
pas disponible en français alors de
toute façon le produit sortira à la fin
de l'année en décembre mais uniquement
dans la langue anglo saxon donc chez les
australiens chez les américains et chez
les anglais dans le reste du monde va
falloir attendre 2018
pour que l'outil soit optimisé et
traduit dans son ensemble donc on n'a
pas de date pour l'instant apple a
effectivement annoncé une sortie dans le
reste du monde en 2018
la date on la connaîtra ultérieurement
autre point négatif c'est le prix 349
dollars l'unité
donc si effectivement vous voulez vous
payer le luxe d'avoir un haut-parleur
dans plusieurs pièces pour garder je
dirais un ensemble sonore complet si
vous êtes dans votre maison vous voulez
pouvoir dans votre appartement ou un peu
importe vous voulez pouvoir changer de
pièce égard débat toujours la même
musique sans forcément être obligé de
mettre à fond et puis entendre le son de
la pièce d'à côté ce qui arrache d'une
vos oreilles et puis de 2 très agréable
pour nos voisins
donc il nous faut plusieurs en mode et
pour avoir plusieurs automne
vous multipliez 349 dollars par le
nombre de modes et au final ça risque de
coûter quand même relativement cher au
final ce petit produit 2 kg 5 à l'air
d'être vraiment sympa il est annoncé en
deux couleurs de ce qu'on a pu voir sur
la présentation de l'appel et sur leur
propre site
on le voit en blanc et en noir donc ça
d'autres effectivement pour l'instant
les deux teintes qui sont présentés il
communiquera en wifi avec l'ensemble de
votre système
et puis comme je voulais dire il va
falloir patienter parce que pour
l'instant on en parle on en parle moins
que vous viviez aux états unis en
australie ou en angleterre vous n'aurez
pas à la fin de l'année à moins d'aller
le chercher de le ramener mais de ne
parler qu'anglais vole un peu ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui en tout cas sur
l'homme potes c'est un produit qui par
contre a l'air d'être sympa d'être
vraiment bien attestée je suis vraiment
très très curieux de tester mais tout
est resté dans une maison de
démonstration avec l'ensemble des objets
connectés
apple pour vraiment se rendre compte de
ce qu'on peut faire sur des vidéos on va
très bien ce qui est présenté quelles
sont les fonctionnalités qu'on peut
faire lever les rideaux allumé la télé
mettre la musique à voir les infos les
ciné ça mais tant qu'on l'a pas vraiment
essayé dans son quotidien ou du moins
essayer en situation réelle c'est
toujours délicat de se racheter
voilà un petit peu ce qu'on peut lire
sur son iphone merci d'avoir regardé la
vidéo dit moi tout ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous tente est ce que pour 349
$ vous seriez vous laisser tenter
349 dollars fois deux fois trois fois
quatre ça dépend des maisons mettez moi
tout en commentaires ou norfolk rémy km
h 2
très très rapidement pour d'autres
informations toujours sur le secteur
[Musique]
et